Concerning the metastasis of cancer to the lungs question from last week, I've tried the
nebulized hydro-aproxide as described by Marcola.
Since I'm due to this, how long and how often should I do this?
So your little nebulizer should only fill up about an ounce of fluid.
You do that, it takes about 10 minutes, maybe 15 minutes to get through that nebulized hydro-aproxide.
And you could do this three, four times a day if you want.
I wouldn't do any longer than that, I wouldn't do any more than that.
But certainly, you could do it three or four times a day, space it out a couple hours
between times that you're doing that.
I would say, yes, can you do nebulized iodine or nebulized baking soda for alkalization?
I don't know, you'd have to look up a recipe for baking soda.
That's a possibility, I don't know the recipe for that.
Iodine, you could, I don't think iodine is going to be a drug killer for cancer that's in the lungs though.
So I would not do the iodine, I would stick to hydrogen peroxide.
You could do colloidal silver, but that's typically more if you have an infection.
You're talking about cancer.
If you can find a recipe for baking soda, that would be fine and hydro-aproxide, it's ticked